[Musique]
je suis Yacine khadesch le fondateur est
SIO de l'entreprise circule egg
circulaire en fait on transforme les
déchets d'aujourd'hui en ingrédient de
demain aujourd'hui on s'attaque au
coquilles d'oeuf qui sont ici des usines
d'industrie agroalimentaire et en fait
on a développé un procédé pour séparer
la coquille de la membrane et ensuite on
revend la coquille externe et la
membrane interne en tant que nouvel
ingrédient pour d'autres filières
industrielles
en fait notre coquille est constitué de
deux parties la coquille externe la
coquille externe est riche à 98% de
carbonate de calcium en gros c'est du
calcium et on la propose un alternative
au coeur bonheur de calcium qui provient
aujourd'hui majoritairement des
carrières de calcaire on a donc un
meilleur impact environnemental et on a
de meilleures propriétés nutritionnelles
le deuxième produit c'est la membrane
interne l'avant-bras interne elle est
riche en différentes deux molécules
d'intérêts avec le collagène l'assise
hyaluronique et cette membrane elle a
des propriétés prouvées pour ce qu'on
appelle le soutien de la fonction
articulaire et la bonne santé de la peau
alors aujourd'hui en fait on vend notre
ingrédient pour d'autres industriels qui
souhaitent avoir des ingrédients
biosourcés recyclés et décarbonés
concrètement aujourd'hui c'est
l'industrie des matériaux l'industrie du
complément alimentaire humain
l'industrie du pet food et de la
cosmétique
Paris Saclay en fait c'est dès la
jeunesse du projet il faut savoir
circuler il est né sur les bancs d'une
des écoles du réseau Paris-Saclay c'est
à savoir AgroParisTech ou quand j'étais
étudiant un groupe à high-tech j'ai
développé le procédé avec des
laboratoires partenaires de
AgroParisTech et donc de Paris Saclay au
sens large et aujourd'hui on travaille
encore avec ses laboratoires on
travaille aussi avec des entreprises qui
sont situées sur le plateau de sacrée
qui sont aujourd'hui nos clients donc
aujourd'hui on a différents types de
partenariats que ce soit de la recherche
publique de la recherche privée et aussi
de développement commercial avec des
entreprises qui font partie de notre
plateau de Saclay à savoir notamment le
secteur du Food
l'année dernière on a eu la chance de
pouvoir participer au sprint 50 en tant
que exposant on avait notre lame de
premier stands et aussi et surtout on a
été lauréat du concours sprint 50 ça a
été intéressant pour différentes choses
bon déjà pour la visibilité que nous a
permis de le sprint 50 mais aussi toutes
les mises en relation avec les
entreprises qui sont nos clients
aujourd'hui et des fonds
d'investissement qui sont aujourd'hui à
bord ce qu'on espère du futur sprint 50
c'est exactement la même chose donc
continuer des mises en relation
pertinentes pour votre business